for movie lovers there are a few
cinematic quotes that are always handy
for breaking the ice or amping up the
drama of a casual chat but many of the
most commonly used movie phrases are
almost always misrepresented in
conversation if you're one of those
people who loves to whip out a famous
movie line in an opportune time you
might want to make sure you're actually
quoting the film's correctly here are
some of the widely mistaken movie lines
in Hollywood history Mirror Mirror the
world of animation changed the day Walt
Disney and his studio released Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs certain
aspects of this classic resonate with
audiences to this day such as the poison
apple true love's kiss and the eternal
question mirror mirror on the wall who
is the fairest of them all the problem
is no one actually says that in the film
well the Evil Queen actually asks is
[Applause]
interestingly enough in the Grimm
brothers original story the Queen says
mirror mirror on the wall who in this
land is fairest of all so heigh-ho
heigh-ho off to correct quoting you go a
[Music]
bigger boat steven spielberg pioneered
the summer blockbuster in 1975 with jaws
his terrifying tale of a great white
serial killer the eerie cello music the
poster the characters and the quotes
they all made jaws the classic movie it
is today the line that's most often
cited from the movie comes from chief
Brody who discovers the deadly creature
is much bigger than they're prepared for
most people quote this famous line from
the scene to say we're gonna need a
bigger boat but what Brody really says
there is
you gonna need a bigger potion it's just
a one-word difference but it's a toothy
one even so if you build it field of
dreams was both a fantasy film and a
sports drama and is often given tribute
with a line if you build it they will
come but the truth of the matter is that
the whispered voiceover never actually
utters that phrase and what's actually
said instead is it's not quite as
compelling in singular format so it's
easy to see why people like to use the
day instead of he but if you're looking
for something more inclusive to spout
out you can always use this line instead
people will come run you fools Peter
Jackson's Lord of the Rings trilogy was
a groundbreaking adaptation of JRR
Tolkien's beloved novels and boasts an
abundance of quotable moments in the
movie the one that seems to be most
often mistaken is from the Fellowship of
the Rings Gandalf lovers often like to
say run you fools but in reality when
our old wizard pal actually says in the
movie is fools why would he say that
when none of his travelling companions
had wings well fly and Old English means
to flee or maybe he's just foreshadowing
the arrival of the Eagles in movie 3
feel lucky punk no matter how many
movies Clint Eastwood directs or stars
in his fans will always remember him as
the man with no name from the spaghetti
western scene and Harry Callahan from
the Dirty Harry series but as quotable
as the latter character is fans often
butcher his biggest line it's much
easier to shorten the scene to state
simply do you feel lucky punk when the
time is right but what he actually says
is you've got to ask yourself one
question do I feel like
well do you think now that you know the
proper dialogue you should feel lucky
play it again
Casablanca is one of the most cherished
films in American history and it's known
for being exceptionally quotable you can
thank the movie for this epic goodbye
line is looking at you kid and this go
to party toast I think this is the
beginning of a beautiful friendship
and let's not forget this lovers lament
of all the gin joints in all the towns
in all the world she walks into mine but
people tend to get it wrong when they
quote the film to say play it again Sam
the misquote even became the title of
Woody Allen's 1972 comedy film but what
Elsa actually says upon walking into the
cafe is played 1 Sam for old times sake
play as time goes by and when Ric wants
to hear it again well this is what he
really says wait a fine plan for me well
I don't think I can stand it I can
plan hey everybody makes mistakes I am
your father
Star Wars is perhaps the biggest
entertainment franchise in the world and
it doesn't seem to be stopping anytime
soon aside from all the lightsabers and
galaxies saving the series contains a
plethora of famous lines from may the
force be with you too I have a bad
feeling about this
the line that seems to get mixed up most
often is when people quote Darth Vader
to tell Luke Skywalker Luke I am your
father but that's a line straight out of
the dark side of audience memories
because what Vader really says is no I
am your father now that you know the
truth the force really can be with you
not in Kansas it only makes sense that
one of the most famous quotes in history
comes from one of the most iconic films
in history The Wizard of Oz when Dorothy
arrives in Oz thanks to a tornado most
people quote her to tell her dog Toto I
don't think we're in Kansas anymore but
that must be some Wicked Witch wizardry
at play because what our Ruby shoe
sporting pal actually says is
not repeating we're not in Kansas
anymore
if you've ever miss read that line aloud
don't worry at least you're not the
Scarecrow thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check all the school stuff
we know you'll love to
[Music]